his hair has brought many jokes to that
nice that's nice with a contentious
general election coming up we went to
the DNC to ask Democrats can you say
something nice about Republicans oh say
something nice say something nice say
them just one thing nice say something
nice
he has not put anyone on any of my
relatives in the crawlspace in a
crawlspace
he hasn't personally hurt you he's not
personally hurt anyone I know that I
know through the trouble he caused last
week that's my man
he came out and he stood his ground for
his wife and said that he will not
support Donald Trump because he made
many comments about it but the country's
best interests said mark
thank you for trying to help education
he's smart break situation
he was awesome on Saturday Night Live he
was you put on hype man hype man
just being on the background
looking like you're in prison
to say she can hold a gun really well
she makes for a lot of great comedic
material increase Alaska national
prominence we do have a state
awesome and finally the Big Kahuna he's
a great way star he knows how to get a
crowd he makes phenomenal ties in Mexico
he seems to really love this family a
lot he loves his family maybe a little
too much it's wonderful Avant is
beautiful I have nothing better they
spawn well they spawn well yes